pierre choc tellier bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
quel est votre sentiment sur ce rapport
de la commission européenne comment est
ce que vous le comprenez bonjour tout
d'abord merci n'avoir invité preuve
c'est assez surprenant de voir réagir
ainsi l'union européenne seront les a
pas beaucoup mieux même moule et on peut
dire qu'elle a été inefficace voire rémy
l'existence lors de la première vague
donc aujourd'hui on est face à une crise
qui donne évidemment ayez une série de
plans économiques qui ont été pour la
plupart imposé par denis européenne est
aujourd'hui ce qu'on dénonce nous en
partie en france est à peu près
similaire dans beaucoup de pays
européens on est très proches de
collègues de belgique et on vient buter
contre la marchandisation de la santé à
l'échelle européenne
alors il selon vous quelle posture doit
adopter la france pour faire suite à ce
rapport de la commission européenne
après le gouvernement entre élites de
l'air de prendre tes propres positions
voilà nous on se bat pour une
reconnaissance de la forte pour que
l'attenté sorte de ce carcan économique
et de cette vision un peu ultralibéral
qu'on peut avoir dessus et on a une
santé qui correspondent aux besoins de
la population alors en gros un cécilia
des hausses de salaires dans les
hôpitaux il va falloir compenser par
d'autres mesures pour l'union européenne
est ce que vous vous craignez que
l'hôpital finalement pâtissent de ces
recommandations de l'union européenne
l'hôpital pâtit déjà de plan économique
successifs je pense que là après on
n'imagine pas l'axé ce qui va y avoir
après le coguic vous voulez mon entre un
état où la précarité de nos populations
a explosé on n'a aucune structure
adéquate pour pouvoir accueillir ces
personnes
l'hôpital est déjà dans un état avant
que le petit arrêt des mentions et qui
était déjà dans un état très préoccupant
et qu'il a aidé en inde et à cadix et
icloud va dire et la presse et du comité
peut être extrêmement compliqué à gérer
et bien plus
bien plus douloureuse que l'imaginent
concernant la hausse des salaires dans
les hôpitaux elle était inévitable
je pense qu'elle était tout à fait
évitable mais je pense que
malheureusement elle est absolument
insuffisante il ya pas qu une question
de faire pour essayer d'attirer des
professionnels et on le voit bien
malgré les augmentations de salaire on a
on a eu l'afflux espérer pour la
deuxième vague
on met en main une carence en fer
d'aggraver faut bien préciser campus
dans le cadre du blanc il est différent
les différentes mutations départ ont été
annulés ou heures c est que l on se
ressemble en beaucoup de nos collègues
vont partir alors vous rendez pas sur
des réseaux là elle est remplacée moins
d'effectifs vous venez nous nous le dire
dans les hôpitaux quels sont les
carences les autres carences que vous
constatez aujourd'hui abats de poissons
c'est toujours les mêmes car enfin on
n'a pas des techniques donc on a
absolument pas de capacitaire en termes
de vie aujourd'hui si vous voulez on a
on n'a presque plus de mal à toucher des
patients non plus vite que des patients
qu'aux vide
donc c'est une situation très compliquée
que l'on vit depuis mais très longtemps
et aggravent d'année en année et que le
coc vide avec lui se fait remonter à la
surface d'énormes problèmes graves et
les difficultés que morrow ans ayant
déjà condamné alors on attend une
nouvelle prise de parole du chef de
l'état la semaine prochaine à quoi
est-ce que vous serez attentif je sais
pas s'il parle beaucoup trop pour qu on
ait de réels inventé beaucoup de
discours en fait n'a même pas grand
chose je sais tu que je sais même pas si
on attendait claude et désaccords de
ségur de la santé par exemple est-ce que
vous en avez vu les truies aujourd'hui
très concrètement de ségur de la
fontaine il a parlé de l'augmentation
salariale
en ce qui concerne les recrutements les
7 me sens en créations de postes vient
d'augmenter les impôts qui est arrivé
les augmentations de 3 millions
on voit le nombre de lits ont été
supprimés 3000 lits une goutte d'eau qui
correspond même pas à la fermeture
annuel délits qui ont exercé sur les
hôpitaux
donc non toute la base de notre
réflexion vous skiez sur le capacité
récent d'accueil la capacité à
accueillir panne on a absolument aucune
réponse dans des galas et inspirent ces
cours ne remet absolument pas en
question le système foncier de l'hôpital
tant sur son fonctionnement économique
que sur son fonctionnement balladuriens
est ce que cette question justement du
système de l'hôpital il pourrait être
géré au niveau européen où il devrait
être gérée au niveau au niveau européen
selon vous en tout cas je pense que
l'europe devrait avoir des plans prévus
en cas de pandémie et que l'on a bien vu
que personne n'était prêt union
européenne d'été après les idées après
donc ça faudrait d'autres questions et
voilà on sait qu'on va être dans une
période
notre héroïne va y avoir de plus en plus
de pandémie que ce genre de deux choses
va se répéter dans le temps et non du
sport dit tiens il faut peut être pas
prévoir les choses
merci beaucoup pierre je crois que
tellier d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je rappelle que vous êtes membre du
collectif interurbain ans